مقطع فيديو عسكري أوكراني يُزعم أنه
يُظهر ضربات على مواقع روسية خلف
الخطوط الأمامية حيث تقول كييف إن قواتها
كثفت
عملياتها الهجومية بشكل كبير واستولت على عدة
قرى خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في
جنوب شرق البلاد.
وأخذ
عدة سجناء في
نفس الوحدة التي كانت ترفع علم أوكرانيا
بعد المعركة التي
حاولوا فيها دفعنا إلى الوراء
بمدفعيتهم ، يقول الجندي إننا نجحنا في
استعادة زمام المبادرة
وحررنا المستوطنة ببطء واحدًا تلو
الآخر
بينما تقول أوكرانيا إنها تهاجم
الروس في عدة  مناطق من
خط المواجهة الشاسع لا تزال كيا كوي حول ما إذا كان
الهجوم الواسع النطاق الذي طال انتظاره قد بدأ بالفعل
رئيس المخابرات العسكرية الأوكرانية في
إصدار هذا الفيديو
لنفسه وهو جالس على مكتبه مع
رسالة خطط الحب الصمت
لكن الروس يقولون إنهم "  إعادة تثبيت
الخط في معظم المناطق ، يُزعم أن مقطع فيديو وزارة الدفاع هذا
يُظهر
مروحية روسية تدمر
مركبات استطلاع أوكرانية في المجموع ،
ويقول الروس إنهم دمروا بالفعل
عددًا كبيرًا من الدروع الغربية المقدمة
بما في ذلك دبابات قتالية رئيسية من طراز ليوبارد ألماني الصنع
وتبرعت الولايات المتحدة ببرادلي
مركبات قتال المشاة ،
لكن وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويغو يوزع الميداليات على
الجنود الروس ، يستمر الاقتتال الداخلي بين
الجيش الروسي وشركة واغنر العسكرية الخاصة في رفض
رئيس فاغنر يفغيني بريغوسيان
الالتزام بمرسوم وزارة الدفاع
لتوقيع عقد مع الجيش الروسي
يقول فيه  المرتزقة أكثر
كفاءة من القوات النظامية
للأسف معظم الوحدات العسكرية لا
تتمتع بمثل هذه الكفاءة كما يقول ، وعلى
وجه التحديد لأن شويغو لا يستطيع إدارة
التشكيلات العسكرية التي
توازن بين الفصائل المتنافسة في آلة الحرب الخاصة به ،
وهي مهمة شاقة لفلاديمير بوتين
حيث احتفلت البلاد بيوم روسيا
بوتين حث الناس على ذلك.  استمر في دعم
حربه في أوكرانيا بينما وصفها بأنها
وقت صعب بالنسبة لبلده ،
روسيا تقوم على الإيمان والأشخاص الذين
قال إن الأشخاص الذين ينتقلون من النصر إلى
النصر يؤسسون حياتهم وكل
عملهم على الإيمان بالإيمان بالنصر الإيمان
الظلم الإيمان بروسيا
شكرًا لك